you've been following this Cadillac XLR
for about six miles DUI swerving all
over the place yeah sir sir mess
how you doing that man I don't or not
you roll the window down
are you trapped did you have any drugs
or alcohol tonight ma'am yeah
yes you can because I can hear you so
you can obviously hear me Travis it's uh
bunny Hernandez that's your mayor's
office the mayor's wife bunny you're
married to a very powerful man very
powerful he is our boss Jimmy is Latino
gentlemen body is still our boss you
came up a long way yeah remember bunny
who used to do the amateur yep yeah yeah
those things you don't have to do that
anymore you got a real nice you are like
you're our new Cadillac baby coming up
the keys went up her bottom crack she's
pooping take your take your britain
drawers off no run you take your panties
off I don't know okay all right we're
just gonna escort you to Tahoe there we
go there we go
got bunny bunny okay bunny a nice lady
doesn't herself in the back seat bunny
bunny would Princess Diana be herself in
the back seat no and you're our princess
die